so after 23 years they finally make a
predator sequel predators the kind of
Chris Hansen probably couldn't catch
okay so let's face it for as much as we
love predator the movies they're one in
four the three movies after the first
one they don't exist but this movie it
takes it back to the roots and I was
just pumped to see people in a jungle
again so this movie pretty much starts
right off I mean badasses fall from the
sky they have their weapons they're in
the jungle you mix them together and the
hunt is on now I'm not gonna lie
predators isn't perfect but it is pretty
cool
I mean first off you notice that they
borrowed heavily from the first movie I
mean if you just look at the cast they
had the exact ensemble the bad in the
first movie like you know they're seen a
predator one where Billy's all like or
something in those trees and he cuts his
chest and [ __ ] the guy and this one
doesn't do that exactly but it's pretty
similar and this movie does have like
the exact soundtrack from the first
predator movie which I'm not gonna lie
that helps the effect like a
billion-fold good call on having that
soundtrack and in this movie the
Predators didn't just come out and start
wasting people I mean they actually
stayed hidden and used hunting tactics
which I mean that was what predator was
all about getting hunted the creepy ass
feeling this movie has I mean come on
predator isn't supposed to be that Paul
WS Anderson predators in the South Pole
[ __ ] it's about the hunt in the
jungle which is what this movie is now
there were a couple things that either
irritated me or just made no sense
like Topher Grace being cast in this
movie at all and I understand that
Topher Grace is character is supposed to
be smart and all that and not only is he
the unofficial twin of mark from schmoes
know but apparently he's the expert on
all things botany and plant life that's
extraterrestrial I mean not really but
apparently he is because he identifies
this plant that's on this
extraterrestrial planet and I've never
seen it on earth I don't think it exists
and there's a segment about halfway
through the movie where they start
hanging out with Laurence Fishburne
who's kind of like Robin Williams from
Jumanji if he was still in Jumanji and
had a tan yeah he's been there way too
long but in this scene the movie slows
way down and he starts talking about how
these predators are like new predators
and they're bigger than the old
predators and they hunt the old
predators because there's this blood
feud going on between them one why do we
need the new predators I like the old
ones and two do not talk about predator
culture I don't care about predator
culture you start talking about predator
culture I just think of a VP and I just
want to cry I mean take predator 1 for
example it didn't touch anything on
predator culture and it's still the best
one because it's all about the hunt just
give me the hunt
okay so bitching aside predators does
take it back to the jungle hunt that we
loved in the first one but the Laurence
Fishburne segment you cut that right out
of the movie and of course you know the
end of this movie's gonna have some
shoutouts to the original I would say
rip offs but rip offs really happened
within like five years after 23 years
they become throw backs it's different
like Adrien Brody delivers
Schwarzenegger line from the first one
he's all like come on do it kill me I'm
here come on kill me do it now do it I
was in splice on I want an Oscar figure
that out kill me I appreciate it but
it's just not the same as come on do it
kill them here come on do it now so tell
me so boring a couple things predators
the official sequel to predator that
we've been waiting for for 23 years not
as good as the original business as
close as you're gonna get check it out
and if your girlfriend dragged you to
Twilight this is your time for revenge
and if you like what you seen here and
you want to see more than click right
here to see more